- So we have to start there
with your top five sports movies,
and they have to be in order.
- Oh, that's tough. In order?
- Yes.
- Um—
- Cuz, you know, the copout
is just to say them all.
You gotta rank the sports movies.
- I gotta rank the sports movies. OK.
I'm going with...No. 1...
oh, man. "White Men Can't Jump."
- Great, great start.
- No. 2, I'mma go with
"Any Given Sunday."
3, I'm going with "Sandlot."
- Mm.
- 4, I'm gonna go with...
"Remember the Titans." And 5,
I'mma go with "Hardball." I'm biased.
- Yeah, gotta pick "Hardball."
- Yeah, yeah.
- There is a big one missing,
but this is all opinion.
There was no, "He Got Game."
- Oh, man, yes.
- Yeah, see, I'mma save you there.
There was no "He Got Game."
- "He Got Game." Yes, all right. I'll swap,
I'll swap "Remember the
Titans" and "He Got Game."
- OK.
- Yeah.
- All right.
Are we missing any other big ones?
I mean, are you like a, are you
like a "Major League"?
Are you a "Jerry Maguire"?
Are you any of—?
- Ah, they don't really rank.
I was gonna say "Space Jam 1."
- Yeah.
- You know what I'm saying?
Just as a straight classic,
but I don't know. "Field of Dreams" was,
I guess, does that count? That counts, right?
- Yeah, that counts.
- Yeah.
- Such an unrealistic plot—
- "Mighty Ducks."
- Like, that's a good one.
- There's too many.
- Yes.
- But your list is solid.
So I'll take that.
- OK.
- And we can start there.
Yeah, you passed that test.